my father taught me many great gifts how
to build the wall we're going to build
the wall how to get a small load with a
million dollars my father gave me a
small loan of a million dollars I came
into Manhattan or loan of a million
dollars and all alone of a small loan of
a million dollars no loan of a moonbow
how to make fun of disabled not that one
but most of all how to be a goddamn
mouth I'm really rich I'll show you that
lesson now where the [ __ ] is calling me
god damn it [ __ ] up wait what's that
what are you saying
my dad Donald Trump it's only hospital
and I'm the only surgeon that can save
him okay this is my calling
let's go Donald Donald can you hear me
I'm crying but now it's not no time for
tears don't you worry I will take great
care of you let me just let me just
touch your face so low Bay oh oh let me
run my fingers through your hair Donald
oh oh oh that feels so natural it feels
so real and not synthetic it's like an
eagle landed on his face and made a nest
there don't worry Donald
don't worry I will make YouTube great
again
now let's have a look at the situation
oh god that is disgusting
well I'm a professional surgeon I'm
gonna have to grab
then you just start don't worry Donald
I've done this never before if you die
can I have another small loan okay I'm
just so opening up your rib case nothing
I wouldn't do it to myself here Donald
have a drink
it's got to be okay Donald just have a
little sip have a little sip see and a
little bit is a little bit of sip for
that
don't worry tell it's good for you it's
Donald Trump quality product oops what
item could possibly be strong enough to
open up his rib case of course the Trump
Tower no what about this golden tomahawk
[ __ ] we're running out of options god I
forgot how difficult this game was if
anything happens to your Trump I will
never forgive myself I am an expert
surgeon there it is the rib cage is open
excellent job dr. Chow Berg thank you
very much
I got your lung from smelly that's the
smell of freedom it also goes for a
great hat and a pillow friend we haven't
got much time trip America needs you
America is counting on you look you're a
eunuch oh oh [ __ ] I didn't mean to pull
that out garbage what the [ __ ] is this
Donald you actually have a heart I
thought you were dead inside what the
[ __ ] this is like that Korean drama I
watched where he gets a heart transplant
and he becomes a good person it's
actually a really good watch and I would
really recommend watching it it's called
beating again like his heart did this is
my favorite scene from the show
just watch either way there's no not
much time to waste
we gotta stop the bleeding surgeon Edgar
oh god I stung myself what the [ __ ] is
this Donald Oh Donald
I stuck myself but don't worry I know
what I'm doing
yeah you like that Donnell you [ __ ]
perv oh god he's bleeding fast nurse
said gotta do something he's bleeding
out goddammit a guy he's bleeding more
now oh god he's bleep super much steak
Brad the steak god damn it my answer
dude I take you're gonna live Trump god
damn it he died the [ __ ] is making that
sound demons are living inside of Donald
Trump this should be news to no one look
you can wear this is such a pain Sentra
honestly like it would look way better
okay I'm gonna stick my hand on purpose
it's tiny now now I can fist you daddy
we got it oh my God he's bleeding fast
oh gotta get it all out my hand is
[ __ ] too tiny honestly we're losing a
head look my dad is too tiny
I can't reach a nurse I gotta hurry the
[ __ ] up what the [ __ ] is this golden
heart golden heart obviously you're my
golden boy I can't breath I can't
hand me the scalpel
that worked that worked the OSI yeah
website the surgery has been
successfully completed oh yes Oh that'll
be half a million dollars he's got it
licked all right Bruce I hope you
enjoyed this episode I can't believe
this is real
I hope they're not gonna get sued for
using Donald Trump likeness in this game
that's [ __ ] awesome
would you give the whole Trump a gold
heart or a stone heart let me know in
the comments thank you so much for
watching I am probably the first one to
have ever played this game on YouTube so
you know that everyone else that's
playing this game they're copying me
this mask oh don't worry about it all
will be revealed soon I'll see you bros
in the next video as always stay awesome
press
[Music]